les cas sont centralisées entre les deux
ars et de guyane et de martinique et la
guadeloupe aussi puisqu'ils sont parties
prenantes et puis et les samu est en
fait en fonction des pathologies il nous
soumettent à des désirs de transfert in
utero de leurs patientes et en fonction
de la disponibilité des lits et des
capacités qu'on a vu qu'on a eu on dit
oui ou non c'est possible au pays si
effectivement on a pu en prendre que une
ce week-end alors qu'il y avait une
demande déjà depuis un certain nombre de
deux jours et deux semaines mais on
était plein il y en avait pas de
possibilité qu'il prend par contre il ya
eu je pense plusieurs enfants qui ont
été transférés ici en réalité on étale
ses des mamans qui ont une grossesse
pathologique avec un risque
d'accouchement le plus souvent
prématurée nécessitant donc pas ce
moment là une prise en charge en
néonatalogie comme ils sont
effectivement en difficulté sur ce plan
là il préfère faire les transferts in
utero plutôt que des transferts
postnataux commence quelle ville ce
transfert de la famille
non je pense qu'elles sont rassurés
parce qu'elles se rendent bien compte
qu'effectivement il ya des difficultés
au niveau du centre hospitalier de
cayenne et que du coup elle se retrouve
dans une structure où effectivement la
prise en charge m meilleure que ce
qu'elle peut être à l'heure actuelle sur
cayenne et donc ça les rassure et je
pense que l'éloignement passe en second
plan non non non non non je pense que là
que la crise elle est simplement très
très très ponctuelles en guyane d'accord
et que ça valait le problème être
rapidement réglés